lilly Reinhardt seemingly shuts down
Cole Sprouse break up reports with one
amazing insta post haven't you heard the
22 year old actress shared her and
Cole's joint W Magazine cover on
Thursday
just days after reports surfaced that
the two had called it quits after nearly
two years of dating but check out Lily's
captions along with the sexy photo the
Riverdale star writes breaking a
reliable source has confirmed that none
of you knows she doesn't need saving
which i think is just awesome
what's more cole posted the same image
along with a similar message quote
unprecedented cole sprouse and Lily
Reinhart consume the flesh of reliable
sources to fuel their back'n alien sex
cult but despite both their posts which
seem to dispel rampant breakup rumors
Lillian Cole's W profile says something
entirely different
noting that the pair would part ways
romantically two months after sitting
down for their separate interviews yes
you heard us Lillian Coulson four
separate interviews back in May it's
cool it's kind of foreshadowing too
as for their reasoning Lily told the mag
quote we're not fighting with the idea
that people group us together but we are
paired up a lot we're acknowledging that
we're in a relationship but it's a small
part of who we are as people we want our
own separate identities meanwhile Cole
argued that Lilly speaks for herself and
deserves her own voice box in every
single way adding quote that alone is
justification enough for me to do it
like this I don't think we're weaving
two different narratives here there's
cracks on the surface of all of these
characters hmm are we buying this the
pair went on to discuss their reasons
behind keeping their relationship
private which has a scratching our heads
even more
Lily said it was initially Cole's idea
telling the mag quote no one knows how
long we've been together
and no one will until we're ready to say
it no one knows how
fell in love except for our close
friends and us it's really special and
the 26 year old actor agreed explaining
that until you go through the paces and
the dating stages and know that
something is right for you I don't think
it's appropriate to bring others in
Betty and Jughead play into each other's
sort of wild emotional and investigative
passions quite a bit but I think yeah I
think but it doesn't end there
Reinhardt and sprouts even tighten the
romance between their Riverdale
characters Betty and Jughead the Ohio
born actress telling the mag if and when
we break up on the show I don't know
it's weird being with an actor you deal
with no one has to deal with and sprouse
explained quote I think part of the fun
that the audience had and still has is
going what's up with them right now it's
interesting but in all honesty my own
happiness and her happiness come before
caring about what people are saying so
while that might have you believing that
bug-head is headed for splitsville
here's what the stars told ET at Comic
Con last weekend I think they're going
strong Jughead goes to prep school this
season so he's only back in Riverdale in
the weekend yeah and I think that's
going to inevitably put stress on the
relationship between Betty and Jughead I
think it might be a little bit tense
they might fall turn away from each
other only to come back together way
stronger and yeah I think they're gonna
I think they're gonna be really good and
that concludes our analysis of Lilly and
Cole's on and off screen relationship
and like you were still totally confused
[Music]